October 1954 that was the date we
mastered gravity control it's like that
cartoon show The Jetsons when that
cartoon was made those technologies were
already developed the average citizens
thinking about well they become a
president and they take them to area 51
they show what aliens look like they
show them what kind of spaceships we
have and then they're supposed to keep
their mouths shut and they get all that
information does that happen or is that
just in movies we're talking about a
major dysfunction of the Constitution
and rule of law on arguably the biggest
secret in the history of the United
States why are they waiting from all
four to now to release these three video
content that we have is orders of
magnitude more significant than the
footage you're seeing on CNN and over
Alaska there was a UFO that appeared the
size of a battleship I have in my
archive the original and they a radar
tape of this
why isn't CNN and Fox News doing this
for these civilizations that are from
various star systems have technologies
that Elon Musk could only dream about
the tesla actually had a prototype car
that was fully an energy out of the
environment the JP Morgan said look if
we can't put a meter on it we don't want
it in order for our civilization to move
forward significantly we're gonna have
to have something better than solar
panels and windmills the good news is we
have it the bad news is there are
sociopaths that don't want us to have it
[Music]
did you ever think you would make it
I said I'm suppose I could take sweet
victory I know this slice meant for me
yeah why would you bet on Goliath but we
got red tape value taming given values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can evaluate this honey run homie
look what I become I'm the one
[Music]
so my guest today is dr. Stephen gorilla
let me kind of give the proper
introduction before we get into it he is
a chairman of emergency doctor which is
the real real bloody stuff that you see
in the emergency room he's seen over 80
thousand patients in his life as a
doctor he also founded the Center for
the Study of extraterrestrial
intelligence and disclosure project
which seeks the disclosure of allegedly
classified secret UFO information he's
written a few books and with that being
said my guest dr. career dr. Greer
thanks for being a guest on by a
tainment love it thank you very much for
having me
so you have an interesting background
because some some talk about when you
read your background you see a lot of
UFO stuff but you know you don't read a
lot about you being a doctor in the
emergency room 80,000 patients can you
kind of give us what you do for living
and what led you to want to study UFOs
well yes I mean I'm a medical doctor and
but when I was younger I had a sighting
of a UFO and it coincided with my uncle
designing what's called the lunar module
which is the thing that put the first
man on the moon
Grumman which is now Northrop Grumman
had the contract to design the machine
that landed with Neil Armstrong so I had
an interest in space and then I had the
sighting not unlike what the Pentagon
recently released where I grew up in
North Carolina and of course I knew
immediately what I had seen was a very
unusual object so it ignited a lifelong
interest in this and a whole lot of
things evolved over time my uncle
retired and over a period of a few years
in the 90s I began to do further
research and start an organization to go
out and do reconnaissance of these UFOs
and set up a set of protocols to make
some kind of interactive contact with
them and we did and that was in 1992
that got on the radar scope of the
intelligence community the head of Army
Intelligence approached me and basically
said what the hell do you think you're
doing basically we had cracked the
Rosetta Stone
for communicating with these objects and
their occupants and it ended up on the
front page of the Pensacola paper in a
March of 1992 and that kind of hit some
red line buttons at the Pentagon and CIA
so I got contacted by those folks some
of them were friendly to what we were
trying to do some were hostile but the
ones who were friendly helped me build a
network that now is around 980 military
corporate aerospace mainly and
intelligence officials who have
information about these projects and
that led to me in 1993 briefing Bill
Clinton's CIA director our james Woolsey
and a few other people Senate
Intelligence Committee members and I was
doing this as a doctor sort of shuttling
up from North Carolina where was
chairman of emergency medicine at the
hospital up to DC so I sort of got
organically sort of overtook my medical
career but over a number of years so I'm
retired from emergency medicine now I'm
not in the ER I'm working now to try to
bring this information and weren't
equally importantly the technologies
that are behind these spacecraft and
things that are being reported on CNN
now because what the public isn't being
told is that we have in fact figured out
how those objects operate and that would
give us an entirely new and advanced
civilization where we would not need
fossil fuels of oil or gas or coal or
nuclear power so it's a very big story
most people think the secrecy around
this is because the government has just
been incompetent and that's not true
that narrative is a false narrative the
true narrative is that I will quote from
a top-secret memo released during the
past few decades but it was dated 1951
and it stated that the subject was the
most classified matter in the US
government exceeding the classification
of the development of the hydrogen bomb
I'm quoting so that document by the way
is up on our website serious disclosure
calm as
iri u.s. disclosure calm so that this
entire investigation that i started sort
of as a interest when i was a young
doctor eventually overtook my medical
career and now I'm sort of working
full-time trying to get this information
out to the public because it's very
critical in order for our civilzation
the move forward significantly we're
gonna have to have something better than
solar panels and windmills and the good
news is we have it the bad news is there
are sociopaths who are in super secret
projects that don't want us to have it
and our civilization has been greatly
harmed not to mention our environment
and biosphere so a lot of people think
this is about aliens I said no it's not
about ETS it's about humans and how
humans gonna get out of the conundrum
were in which is a very serious problem
and move forward as a civilization
instead of sliding backwards so going
back to you sell a lot of different
things I just want to kind of make it
clear what it means you said nine
hundred and eighty military intelligent
officials that give you information' AKA
whistle blow right is that a fair
assessment and within documents for
example a lot of top-secret documents in
1998 my group working with a
constitutional attorney Daniel Sheehan
that's in our new documentary Close
Encounters of the fifth kind which is up
on all the platforms now he and I looked
at this issue and if you have a minute
to hear me out what happened I don't
know if you can imagine the strange
predicament a doctor is in who's of
course uncle was one of the pioneers in
aerospace with Northrop Grumman working
on the Apollo mission was to be asked to
come up to Washington the brief the
sitting CIA director as a civilian on a
subject because the president and he
were being denied access now let me
repeat this the President of the United
States and the director of the CIA were
being denied I have a FedEx letter from
the person setting up this meeting
between me and the CIA director Woolsey
that states that they had inquired about
this subject they
there were programs going on highly
classified and they were denied access
to it I didn't believe that could be
true I thought this is a bad john
lecarre novel and when I got up to DC
and met with the director of the CIA I
realized nobody was joking that this is
absolutely true and that's when I
realized in December 1993 that our
country the Constitution the rule of law
had completely run off the rails at
least in this specific area and it was
pretty much what Eisenhower if you
looked at last speech Eisenhower made
when he left office when he said beware
the military-industrial complex because
it will become a threat if we're not
careful to our democracy and our way of
life but that was his farewell speech
and this is a five-star general World
War two hero of course and a Republican
and and no one really understood why he
made that as his last speech well it
turns out one of his military guys who
worked with him the last couple years of
his administration I was an old guy that
I got to know was one of our disclosure
project whistleblower said oh yeah I was
at the White House and Eisenhower had
been pushed aside and had lost control
of those projects so I think this is the
part of the story that people have a
hard time in a sense getting their minds
around because we all grew up with our
history lessons and our civics lessons
and that president is the commander in
chief and blah blah blah
in reality the emperor has no clothes
and there are classified projects that
go on unfortunately that are not
supervised by the President or the
Congress so that led me with with Daniel
Sheehan to conclude that these projects
were illegal a priori they cannot claim
the rule of law to suppress testimony
and disclosure of the subject so we
concluded that we could go forward with
top-secret documents and witness
testimony and put it out to the public
and that's what we have been doing
that's one part of this story that more
interesting part of the story actually
isn't the governmental part it's the
fact that our team in the 90s and up
till now had developed protocols where
we could interact with these
civilizations and Vector them into a
site like you would vector a jet into
JFK Airport and the movie Close
Encounters of the fifth kind is sort of
a two-hour tour through what we've been
doing and what the results have been and
it's for people who see it it's sort of
shocking when they realize this and what
I tell people is that when you're
dealing with civilizations and actually
the CI directors wife who at the time
was chief operating officer of the
National Academy of Sciences said to me
at during our a two or three hour
meeting with the CI director she turned
to me she said how are these
civilizations communicating across the
vastness of interstellar space because
the speed of light is too slow and for
people who aren't scientists on your
viewership let me explain at the speed
of light to go one percent of the way
across our own galaxy the Milky Way
would take it which is a thousand light
years which is the distance light goes
at 186,000 miles every second for a year
that's one light year a thousand light
years is one percent of the way across
our galaxy which is one galaxy amongst
trillions but at the speed of light for
you to even communicate and say hey how
are you doing and to answer back that
would be the time since the birth of
Christ two thousand years for that
transmission to happen with what you and
I are using right now on electromagnetic
signals so we knew as scientists and and
that there had to be something else that
these civilizations were using and what
we discovered was that they have very
high very sophisticated electronics and
this is of course what Elon Musk at
neuro-link he has a company called
neural ankus is working on that
interface with directed thought
now this is probably where I've lost
half your audience and they're going
what in the reality is there's an area
of what's called the science of
consciousness field consciousness where
at Princeton with dr. John who is a
engineering professor discovered that he
could set up a technology a random
number generator that spits out random
zeros and ones and put someone in a room
and have that person intend through
their thought not touching it no wires
for the random number generator to spit
out more ones and zeros and it would and
it did it consistently and so he began
to ask the question how can the
consciousness field and thought affect a
quantum random number generator which is
what he was using and so that unleashed
an entire area of physics which people
think sounds very obtuse and and sort of
mystical but it isn't and what we what
we had discovered when I was younger is
that in fact these civilizations that
are from various star systems have
technologies that Elon Musk could only
dream about in other words they were
very accurately transmitted and send and
receive directed quanta of thought
instead of an electromagnetic signal per
se through what's called field
consciousness and conscious the
consciousness field is I mean it sounds
very Buddhist or Vedic but the
consciousness field is actually not
bound by space time space or time and
because of that there's no limit on the
speed of it it's instantaneous
because of what's called nonlocality in
physics is a bit obtuse and and
technical to get into probably here but
what nonlocality means is that it's not
based in the speed the linear speed of
light or the lid linear speed of sound
or what-have-you it's instantaneous
because of the nature of conscious field
the field of consciousness
and this is the to me the most
interesting stuff because this whole
science of consciousness is actually the
big science for the next 1,000 years but
we have to catch up to the last seventy
to a hundred years of energy to end
propulsion technologies that have been
hidden away so we don't destroy the
biosphere but this is what really led me
to leave my medical career four years
ago and say you know what this has got
to get addressed in some sort of a
credible way so we started this research
project to do that and a close encounter
of the fifth kind this documentary what
that is is when humans initiate the
contact with these civilizations and
they respond that's what a ce-5
shorthand is and so we've also developed
an app it's called the ce-5 contact app
so in all the stores you know google and
itunes so that people can learn how to
do the techniques to do this and now we
have a hundred thousand people around
doing it having all these amazing
experiences with these models boid can
we get a little bit more deeper into
this because here's what I don't want I
want the audience that's watching this
doesn't speak your language so assume
none of us are physicists none of us are
doctors we're regular people that run
businesses companies investors founders
radio gets smarter so when you use the
bigger words you lose us immediately but
I learn when you're saying 186 miles a
second for one year as a lighter I
didn't know that before so I feel
smarter just hearing that back from you
okay so back to the basics let's go back
to the basics sure you said something
very interesting to go back to you said
that when Eisenhower gave this speech
and you're talking about a five-star
general in the past or even the Clinton
situation or even some other presidents
are you saying some of these projects
that they're working on with UFOs or
unidentified you know let's just talk
about UF was first and aliens are you
talking about this is a project that's
even bigger than a President of the
United States meaning it's not even at
that level that some of this stuff
they're not even gonna know it's
classified beyond the normal briefing
for the president yes
and what does that mean so you know you
know when a bomb abhi came a president
first and he went on Jimmy Kimmel and he
sat there and they asked him a question
and you know Jimmy says look if I was a
president first the first thing I would
do is okay I'm president I'm gonna go
get checked out to see if there's really
a Lian's and then Obama says that's why
you're not a president or you know
because and it's just yeah but tell me
do aliens exist and then because Bill
Clinton said no and then Obama said well
that's what we're supposed to tell you
that's what we're told to tell you and
then recently they asked Trump I think
Tucker Carlson asked Trump and about
presidents I'm sure you saw that when
Tucker asked Trump a so what do you
think about UFOs and he says I'm not a
believer but anything is possible he
said that on the interview with Tucker
Carlson are these our presidents you
think like this situation where the
average citizens thinking about well
they become a president and they take
him to area 51 they show what aliens
look like they show him what kind of
spaceships we have and then they're
supposed to keep their mouths shut and
they get all that information does that
happen or is that just in movies that's
just in movies and it depends on the
president let me give you an example in
the case of that we had a president
years ago named Ronald Reagan and he was
briefed in a limited way on the subject
but with a psychological warfare
objective to get him to support SDI
space you know the so-called Star Wars
objects in space and they're in a bubble
you know I mean Truman said and then
Clinton repeated that the White House is
the crown jewel of the federal
penitentiary system and that it really
is true so everyone thinks that you come
out of the Webber ray or businessman
like Trump or peanut farmer like Jimmy
Carter and you become president and you
have an absolute all-access pass and
that is true for conventional
intelligence and military operations
with the unconventional ones and the
proper name of that is an unacknowledged
special access project USA P in fact
there's a documentary that came out
three years ago that's on net
if you have Netflix called
unacknowledged that we did it's globally
has had over 600 million views that you
can see the new documentary is is a
follow-on to that one but the
unacknowledged special access projects
is the proper military term for projects
that are off the books deep black and no
one is briefed on them who is not
doesn't have a need to know so you would
say well the president has a need to
know everything but those projects have
irrigated to themselves the fact that oh
no you don't and let me give you an
example I want you I want to make this
less abstract and more concrete for
people I was at the Pentagon briefing
wasn't called J to the head of
intelligence Joint Staff so you were in
the military so this is the guy who is
the director of intelligence for the
briefings for the Joint Chiefs of Staff
of the United States and he had asked to
have a briefing by me and some of the
people on my team because one of my team
members knew him and had reached out
before I went to the briefing I sent him
a document through courier that was a
briefing summary and that that's the top
document on it was a document that
listed some of the code names and code
numbers for those projects based on that
he recognized one of them he wasn't sure
what they did and he contacted them and
basically he was threatened he was the
first thing they said to him was this is
Admiral Tom Wilson by the way and
Admiral Wilson was told a sir you don't
have a need to know and he said god damn
it how can I not have a need to know I'm
the head of intelligence for the Joint
Chiefs of Staff and they said sir we
will not discuss this with you
when he continued to push on the matter
he was threatened with being demoted and
having a star taken off his lapel so you
can imagine by the time astronaut Edgar
Mitchell who was the sixth man to walk
on the moon and I and some of our people
walk into that office because this
happened before my stand-up briefing at
the Pentagon
he was furious but scared and so the
public thinks that you know God is in
heaven and everything is in orbit and
everything is that we actually are
living in a situation where the extreme
secrecy Eisenhower warned us about the
worse of that has come to fruition and
frankly no one is reporting that
certainly not the mainstream news media
so what has happened and what would this
sort of through the looking-glass that
happened to me was that from that
experience I then had a briefing a
couple years later with General Patrick
Hughes now four people don't know who he
was he was the three-star general who is
the director of the Defense Intelligence
Agency which is like the CIA for the
Pentagon is the big clearing operation
for intelligence gathering and
assessments and analysts and the
director of the Defense Intelligence
Agency general Hughes had made inquiries
through proper channels onto the subject
and he was denied access so I was asked
to come in with my military adviser and
a couple other people to brief him and
he told the same story in fact he went
over to his bookshelf now imagine this
I'm at the Pentagon where the generals
and admirals that part of the Pentagon
he goes over to in his conference room
goes over to the to his bookshelf picks
up a little eat he doll like you'd get
at a store toy store and he said
furiously he says this is all I've ever
gotten in my inquiry about this through
channels as the director of the Defense
Intelligence Agency so he was furious
obviously and I said look you're not the
he says well who else is in this
situation I said well the president the
director of the CIA j2 Admiral Wilson
yourself a couple of the members of the
Senate Intelligence Committee I have
briefed etc ironically one of them was
senator dick Bryan whose territory was
so called area 51 Nellis Air Force Base
and he had no knowledge of this so now
when I say this
I want to clarify something there have
been DC ice directors of Central
Intelligence who have been read in or
briefed there have been dia generals who
did know and people say well why do son
know and some don't
it's whether they come up with the
pedigree through these you SAP
unacknowledged black black super black
projects and are trusted to keep the
secret so if they've come up through
that system they may know if they
haven't come up through that system
which is an alternative reality frankly
they're not gonna know because they
haven't been cleared and read into it
and it's not known by the people
controlling these projects that they
would in fact maintain the strict level
of secrecy and who do this is not just
this is not just the United States by
the way the same situation exists in
Great Britain Australia I've met with
ministers of defense in in most of the
five eyes countries which are of course
you know New Zealand Australia Canada
Great Britain us and in fact except for
New Zealand I've met with mo D or
defense folks in all those countries and
it's an enormous problem because we're
talking about a major dysfunction of the
Constitution and rule of law on arguably
the biggest secret in the history of the
United States and when that happens a
lot of bad things will occur but things
go wrong when things are not being
overseen properly and controlled
properly and that's the situation we
face so what I concluded by the year
2001 which was of course now 19 years
ago in May Maine as is almost the the
19th anniversary
um 2001 may 9th at the National Press
Club
we held a briefing of further press and
I had 22 top-secret military people
there and it was covered globally but as
it began to get covered by the news
media in the United States the
intelligence community contacted those
media outlets and
them to take it down and they did so the
other myth that people have is that on
the things that are really important
that we have a free press we do not
actually the Soviet Union had a freer
press than we do on this so ironically
there's a there's a really big problem
with the u.s. function because of this
level of frankly corruption there's
nothing else to call it corruption and
it has really hurt our democracy but
it's also hurting our economy people
often say you know why are we still
using jet engines from the 30s 40s 50s
or rockets from the 40s I'm saying
because the alternative would completely
terminate the petrodollar system and oil
and gas and coal and nuclear power and
public utilities all of it is redundant
completely unnecessary now people say
well then the Cure may be worse than the
disease I said no there's no disease
worse than a terminal event for the
biosphere so going back to when you were
talking about those organizations that
are separate then even the director of
CIA or any of our leaders knowing you
are they recruiting that's different
that's underground we don't know about
are they recruiting military folks or
they're recruiting different backgrounds
both I mean sigh I know scientists who
work in skiffs and secure communication
information facilities it's got a skiff
who are civilian who work on these
projects
I know corporate folks with science
applications international corporation
or Lockheed skunkworks my uncle's old
company Northrop Grumman there's a lot
of contracting but it's very very highly
compartmented in the government it's
similarly highly compartmented and and
the proper name you know you know people
use the term deep state
it's an incorrect term the proper term
is an unacknowledged special access
project you know it's a good tutorial
for the President to learn the proper
lingo frankly for this and and this is
the world I've been steeped in for
thirty years now but I think we we have
a situation
where the the corporate classified
sector is where the research and
development and technology is mainly
happening but under the aegis of you SAP
unacknowledged special access projects
from the military and intelligence
community so it's sort of a hybrid
operation between a corporate and
governmental very top-secret program yes
that's interesting to know that because
it's even a whole different level than a
CIA or a Delta Force you're talking
about a league of its own is what it is
so you mentioned earlier that one of the
reasons why maybe these conversations
are not being had because many
industries would take a big hit and so
to control it I think it's a quote you
gave about when Tesla was able to build
a car without an engine or without a
battery and I think he was talking to an
entrepreneur at the time I don't know if
it was Edison or a Ford who was that he
was Tom he was talking to JP Morgan was
talking to jokah Tesla Tesla actually
had a prototype car that was pulling
energy out of the environment and he
didn't really understand what that was
we do now it's called zero-point energy
or quantum vacuum energy but basically
just for people who are non-scientific
it not scientists if you visualize a
coffee cup the amount of space inside
that cup has enough energy to boil off
all the oceans of the planet in its
potential and it's called the zero-point
energy field is being quantified it was
in academic papers in the 50s so called
professor Casimir Casimir effect but
Tesla stubbl stumbled across this back
way back early 20s I believe maybe
before but JP Morgan said look if we
can't put a meter on it we don't want it
so Tesla died a very bitter man I always
joked that Elon Musk doesn't have a
Tesla that he's manufacturing he has a
musk and the reason I say that jokingly
is that of true Tesla would net
have to be plugged into the grid it
would be pulling energy out of this
energy this state of energy that's
around us through very high voltage
systems they're called vhv very high
voltage systems that create an opening
into that energy field and Tesla did
enough experimentation with these sort
of very high voltage systems at certain
resonant frequencies cycles per second
Hertz that he broke that he broke into
that area of science but no one wanted
it to come out now you know fast forward
a hundred years later we're still
burning gasoline in engines and rocket
fuel and jets and that's a tragedy for
the human race but it's a tragedy for
the planet and it's a tragedy for our
children and my nine grandchildren so my
concern is you know the future the past
is the past but we have to figure out
how to catch up I sort of back to the
future we you know it's like those that
cartoon show the Jetsons
when they showed people flying around in
these cars when that cartoon was made
those technologies were already
developed going back to what you said
about Free Press uh you were mentioning
the fact that we think we have a free
press what we don't were you alluding to
a project Mockingbird yes of course
project Mockingbird and there are others
that existed where for example a
constitutional attorney Daniel Sheehan
that's in this new documentary Close
Encounters of the fifth kind he states
that when he was representing the New
York Times in the Pentagon Papers
scandal back in the 70s during the
Vietnam War he saw a document that
listed it listed 42 different people who
were senior national security editors at
major media who were also dual-purpose
on the payroll the CIA and he thought
this was a very significant thing in
terms of freedom of the press and
independence of the press and but nobody
would let that story get reported
because it's is scandalously corrupt
because the the Free Press and the
Fourth Estate is one of the pillars of a
democracy and that sort of gives like
get get sort of a makes a mock project
Maki murdered and they made a mockery of
that and then you know in my own
adventures back in the 90s I was meeting
with Bob Schwartz in New York he was on
the board of time-life which became AOL
Time Warner blah blah blah and you know
he was an older gentleman who had you
know good friends with Mike Wallace at
60 minutes and what-have-you and I was
with him at a gathering in New York I
was doing a briefing for a lot of the
New York I hate to use the word elites
but the you know leaders the so-called
New York 100 and when I was at this
meeting he turned to me he says you know
the Fourth Estate is dead that's what do
you mean he says were scribes taking
dictation from the right hand of the
king he says we don't have a Fourth
Estate there is no free press in the
United States on the things that really
matter and then he told me this story
mr. Schwartz told me the story of you
know his friend Mike Wallace of 60
minutes was given some documents about
these UFO covert programs and Mike
Wallace wanted to do the story and CBS
the 60 Minutes say you will not do this
story and and Mike Wallace went into a
very deep depression over this that he
later admitted to the public that he was
very depressed but he and and he said on
Larry King I had been on Larry King
around this time and he said on Larry
King Live which was a post on CNN back
in the old days and he said I'm a fraud
and and Larry said what do you mean
you're a fraud
to Mike Wallace and he wouldn't go into
the details but this is the back story
Bob Schwartz told me look you know he
was devastated that the biggest story
that would have been ever in
investigative journalism CBS jumped in
and killed it and wouldn't let it be
broadcast or even pursued on 60 minutes
which of course
at that time was the blue-chip
investigative reporting you know news
magazine on network television so that's
one of the this is something that's sort
of a side issue to what I'm working on
but it's a big part of why when you turn
on your television set even if you get
these leaked Pentagon videos that came
out they re-released them this past week
you probably saw them on CNN or
elsewhere they're not gonna say a we
know what these are B we know where they
come from see we figured out how they
work let me give you a date that's gonna
probably curl your toes October 1954
that was the date we mastered gravity
control now why do I mean by gravity
control what I mean by gravity control
our high voltage systems that cause an
object to what looks like levitate or
move the way that vehicle that you saw
in that video released by to the
Pentagon this week and they confirm yes
this is real footage and they released
three different videos what they didn't
say because the people releasing it
don't know this because of the
compartmentalization is that there is an
unacknowledged compartmented program
that began studying this in the 40s and
50s and by 1954 had figured out how
those ought things operate so not to
confuse your viewers any more than I
probably already have but so when you
see one of these objects you have to ask
a question is it a classified aerospace
project from the Lockheed skunkworks or
my uncle's company northern Grumman or
is it interstellar extraterrestrial and
both are out there by the way but no
one's asking the question is it a or b
and that's a very big fault of the
so-called they're not asking none what's
gonna asking the right questions yes
well why not ask that question it
doesn't seem like it's a big deal of a
question well because the the reportage
on this never goes that deep it get it's
just here's something that got released
what is it we don't know on to the next
but you know why they waited I mean this
happened in Oh for it's not like this
happened just three months ago and and
even the Navy pilot I think his
Underwood Chadha Underwood who was
flying it he says you know I saw this
thing and you know you've seen this
before video and he's explaining it and
even X UFO program chief release
Elizondo says we may not be alone here
you know why are they waiting from oh
four to now to release these three
videos well my own assessment of that is
about two and a half years ago when they
first surfaced this documentary called
unacknowledged went viral and literally
has had over 600 million people see it
the counterintelligence people at the
Pentagon which includes Lewis Elizondo
wanted this footage to come out but with
the narrative that it's a threat to our
national security
if you look at the Sabrosa narrative
most of the narrative excuse me there's
a beam of light coming from the sides
there there's you if you look at that
narrative what they have been saying is
yes this is real but it's a threat to
our airspace as a threat to her pilots
why well there's a man named Wernher von
Braun who invented the rock a tradeoff
Hitler he became the foundation of our
space program his spokesperson for the
last five years of his life is on my
team Carol rosin and she said look he
said what they're going to do there's
going to be global there's gonna be the
Cold War than global terrorism then
other threats from outer space and
they're the final card they're going to
play is the alien threat card and it's
all a hoax it's all a lie and this gets
into how people who have these sort of
agendas can exploit a subject and make a
disaster out of something that shouldn't
be a disaster you know it's not unlike a
storming into Iraq during the after 9/11
when there was an ascent illa of
evidence that Iraq had
thing to do with 911 which now has
destroyed that entire region of the
Middle East and even Trump has said that
you know that was a huge mistake but
here we are you know all these years
later what I'm concerned about is that
that release was timed to hijack the
narrative away from the fact that we're
not alone in the universe we have these
objects we understand how they work that
needs to be disclosed and we need to
make peaceful contact with these
civilizations not be shooting them down
with lasers but the narrative that the
intelligence community has begun to
create is unfortunately one of a threat
matrix where they're adding to the
threat make tricks this alien threat and
I can assure you having worked with
everyone in every compartment literally
nearly a thousand people Vinny's
projects there's not a scintilla of
evidence that these are a threat to our
national security or to the human race
now I will say that they think that
humans are a threat they think that
humans are actually becoming a threat
because we're dangerously destroying
this planet's biosphere we're beginning
to go out in space with killer
satellites and we have been targeting
these et spacecraft for a number of
decades with increasingly sophisticated
classified weapon systems not who's made
you said they are worried that we are a
threat who's they the extraterrestrial
civilizations they think we're a threat
yes and to ourselves and others you know
I own a laugh as an emergency doctor if
somebody really crazy comes into the
emergency department where they're
mentally ill and they're our threat to
themselves or others they're put in an
involuntary commitment because you don't
want them to kill themselves or kill an
innocent person I think that these
civilizations view humans at this stage
of being becoming extremely
technologically advanced
but not socially and spiritually
advanced enough to handle it and we're
you know obviously have weapons of mass
destruction that you know about what
your audience doesn't know about is that
there are multiple generations of
electromagnetic weapons that are much
more dangerous than a hydrogen bomb that
have been developed and those have been
put on satellites that have targeted
these et spacecraft and this when I this
was the main reason by the way i briefed
that the head of the defense
intelligence agency he had heard
rumblings of this and knew that it was
an existential threat to the peace and
security of not just United States but
of our civilization how do you know that
the extra-terrestrial thinks we are a
threat how does well a lot of it is
observational for example when the Minot
North Dakota intercontinental ballistic
missile silos where we have our big
nuclear intercontinental weapons was
breached by UFOs back in the 60s the the
men that were in the silo a number of
whom are on my team said that the
message that they were receiving from
the behavior what they did what the ETS
did they took eight at least 18 of those
multiple warhead intercontinental
ballistic missiles offline they rendered
them unlaunchable but they did it only
as a way of saying please don't blow up
this beautiful planet but if you do go
to a full launch we can minimize it and
this has been one of the things that I
talked to if you look at the disclosure
project materials I have an interview
with Colonel Dietrich who was the head
of the nuclear a supervisory group for
the Air Force but also the old Atomic
Energy Commission and he said every one
of our atomic weapons and space
facilities had been served surveyed by
these ETS and they had all concluded
that they were not doing anything to
threaten us
but they thought that we had become a
threat to ourselves and could
potentially in the future be a threat
existential threat out in space so
humans being so narcissistic we always
are thinking oh I don't understand what
this is it's a threat to me the irony of
this is that we're actually the out of
control primates rampaging around the
planet
with endless wars and now covertly
putting programs up into space that are
extremely powerful technologies on
satellites that are a threat so this is
a very complex issue that we've gotten
into but this was also why when Boutros
boutros-ghali was un secretary-general i
had a meeting with his folks with him
and his wife and it was a discussion
about how do we approach this issue in a
way that de-escalates it and where we
have some kind of rational diplomatic
outreach to whoever are in these UFOs
the ones that are not man-made
and that's what the Close Encounters of
the fifth kind is the ce-5 initiative is
all about doing that it reminds me a
little bit of what we did in the Cold
War there's a group called physicians
for Social Responsibility that were
American physicians that went over to
the Soviet Union to create some sort of
dialogue to try to defuse this mutual
assured destruction
you know atomic clock getting too far
out of hand where we may go to DEFCON
one and launch all our missiles and what
we're doing with close encounters is a
fifth kind of sort of a citizen's
diplomacy outreach these civilizations
using some rather novel and the perhaps
controversial protocols and techniques
but that work and they're based on what
I was talking about earlier nonlocality
and consciousness and connection to
these objects they have very
sophisticated systems that can interface
with people who go into what some people
would call a deep meditative state who
can remove you now the remote-viewing
term is from the CIA back in the 70s
where they trained people to basically
spy on the Soviet Union using
consciousness and it was a very
successful program if you look at dr.
Russell Targ and others he's a physicist
who was in that program for 23 years
they had enormous success using that
we're using that not to spy but to make
contact and to create a liaison between
humans and those civilizations because
our government has completely failed us
and frankly so is the United Nations so
that's why we're taking this wide
through doing this documentary you know
you you are the way you speak is
incredibly convincing and you obviously
come across extremely confident you have
an incredible voice you have a track
record 80,000 patients emergency doctor
MD you breathe Pentagon all these other
places you've been but the way you
explain that the extra-terrestrial is
concerned more about us and we ought to
be they're worried about them you say
that in a way of certainty like you're
100 percent confident that that's what
it is you're not saying it with I
believe that's what they're thinking
you're saying that they are concerned
that's a definite answer you're given
how could you give a definite answer and
not saying this is what my feelings are
because I've spent 30 years leading a
team that has made contact with these
civilizations
you've spent okay so let me ask you a
question have you you talked about the
five different levels of encounters
right if you don't mind explaining to
five different encounters oh yeah we can
do that so a close encounter of the
first kind is when an object is seen
within a reasonable distance where you
can actually see the structure of it a
close encounter the second kind is when
there's some physical evidence that is
left like it lands it leaves evidence
like the Bentwaters case in England or a
radar where it's on radar like you saw
there where there's some clear physical
evidence that is resulting everyone
knows what close encounter the Third
Kind is from the Steven Spielberg
B is when there is a counter with an
actual extraterrestrial biological
entity an EBE a close encounter of the
Fourth Kind is when someone has an
experience where they are taken on board
one of these craft and then a close
encounter of the fifth kind is when
humans instead of these being a those
other for passive events a close hair of
the fifth kind is when humans initiate
the communication in contact and under a
mutual conditions so that's what a close
Karen the fifth kind is would you define
which of the five have you personally
experienced all five you've personally
experienced all five yes
so you've personally had interaction
with extraterrestrial aliens out there
yes personally yes and you're 100% about
that yes
has it been a face-to-face or it's been
through the energy face-to-face you
face-to-face met and alien before yes
and how old were you when this happened
first time that happened I was 18 and
it's a very interesting story I wrote a
book some years ago called hidden truth
forbidden knowledge which is kind of a
story about my life how I got involved
with this and before I was in college
when I was a senior in high school I got
very sick and had a near-death
experience and I was raised in a
scientific family where you know if it
didn't fit into a test tube or whatever
it didn't exist so I was raised in an
atheist scientific reductionist but
family so I didn't have any belief
systems about the pearly gates and the
listened to that nevertheless the truth
is what it is I got very sick
I died a near-death experience obviously
came back to life but in that process
had this amazing experience with what
mystical literature recall cosmic
consciousness or that state of oneness
with the conscious being of the cosmos
and I was out in this in space when this
happened
because I had a great love for the earth
and space I didn't really care about the
religious traditions because I didn't
wasn't raised that way and that
experience taught me that I really
needed to understand what consciousness
was what the the light of consciousness
within us is so I began on my 18th
birthday coincidentally I learned
meditation and when then went off to
college so I'm up in North Carolina I'm
up in the Blue Ridge Mountains I hiked
up this mountain and I'm meditating a
little before sunset but just before I
close my eyes I look out and the same
spacecraft that I saw when I was a child
eight or nine years of age appeared
again or it looked the same and it
appeared it materialize and
dematerialize it didn't just fly in and
out like you see an airplane and I went
oh that's interesting they're back you
know I didn't think more about it i sat
down and meditated and at the end of the
meditation it lasted very long it had
gotten quite dark and I've up over five
thousand feet up in the Blue Ridge and
it's very clear in October of 73 and I
look up and in the beautiful Milky Way's
above and I then see that there's this
to be honest with you and I know this
sounds ridiculous but you asked I'll
tell you I thought it was a deer
standing on its hind legs upright like a
human and had these beautiful deer like
eyes and then I realized it wasn't a
deer I was very disoriented at what the
hell is this it came over and touched me
on my right shoulder and actually so
much I had a ski jacket on
I could see it indent and it touched me
and there was this electromagnetic field
that went around me bang I vanished off
the mountain and I was on this craft for
I don't know maybe I'm gonna guess
around three or four hours and that's
what happened to me when I was 18 and it
sounds like an unbelievable story but
that led me into really wanting to
pursue how these civilizations travel
how they communicate so in that
experience when I was on this object we
I did this meditative process with these
beings
and created these Close Encounters of
the fifth kind protocols and I did do
anything with it publicly for many many
years that was in 73 I didn't emerge do
anything public with this until the
early 90s but what I did do is I began
to experiment with it and every time I'd
experiment with it where I was up up in
the mountains of North Carolina one of
these objects would appear and I kind of
got a little bit I said you know I don't
think I should be doing this unless I
you have a better reason so I stopped
and in the movie close to Karis 215
you'll see a couple years later I'm
becoming a teacher of meditation this is
before I'm at the Medical School and I'm
up in the Alps in the French Alps and
the maritime Alps and one morning I
decide to do this technique so I go into
quiet meditation I Remote View where
these ET objects are and I show them
reverse the process and show them where
I am up in the Alps near Isola prawns
and and that's it I do it for maybe an
hour during the meditation I go out with
some friends after lunch and this
massive tetrahedron appears in the
crystal blue sky and in the documentary
that's out now close cares of fifth kind
a friend of mine who was with me then we
were 19 years old maybe Ted turned 20
very young and this object appears and
descends towards us and she goes Steve
what did you do did you can't I sit yes
of course she's now freaking out frankly
I go Marian relax or find or just you
know but so that happened and then a
couple years later I tried it one more
time and that event led to that case
that is in the movie with the police
helicopter and the airline pilots in
Charlotte North Carolina that saw these
objects after I engaged in that protocol
again so I began experimenting with it
periodically but didn't formalize a
project around it until
t90 about 30 years ago so let me ask you
at that time were you at all using
recreational drugs
LSN I don't ever never ever have done
any of those things never have used any
of those things
okay so then when you had that cosmic
moment how do you know that wasn't a
dream
and it was a real moment how do you
you're pretty smart guy you're a
well-read person you you're not somebody
that just jumps too how do you how do
you differentiate but maybe it was just
a dream that I had because we've had
some wild dreams in our lives well if
you talk to neurosurgeons and other
doctors who've dealt with patients
who've died and they've been
resuscitated
it's an unmistakable experience where
you go above and out of your body and
out and can observe things you know I
mean I guess if somebody is hell-bent on
not believing this as possible you can
explain it any way you wish but there's
too much evidence around that and and
ultimately I know what I experienced it
was certainly not a dream now I have had
lucid dreams of the future and things
like that I mean you know I think this
is very common in society people have a
dream and the next day or year later it
happens I met actually my wife that way
a series of lucid dreams but I think
that that it has the ability with the
development of consciousness and
meditation the more people the more
people are in touch with the meditative
state and develop these conscious
abilities the more those things
spontaneously happen but the truth is
every person who is sentient and
conscious has these abilities within
them and which is why when you do a poll
of the public huge percentage of the
public have had precognitive dreams
lucid dreams of the future maybe
episodic telepathic episodes and a large
number of people have had a near-death
experience where they recount a similar
pattern of events that occur do you
believe in God
well it's Ephrata dword isn't it god I
believe in us the Great Spirit the
unbounded being you call it God when you
use the word God in our society it
conjures up an angry man up on a cloud
throwing lightning bolts down on creator
but I believe in a creator do you
believe
oh absolutely yes are you absolutely
we're in a creator okay I did I didn't
when I was younger because we were I
mean we were very devout atheist what
when did that happen when did you come
home was that around the same time
eighteen nineteen or is it was it past
that when I when I had the near-death
experience I mean that that's when you
believe in a creator well because I
experienced that state yeah so
experiencing that state is different
from you know the catechisms of reading
a Bible or something I think you know I
always tell people the great teacher is
experienced and the foundation of
science by the way is empiricism
observation experience so if you
experienced something like that that
goes a lot further than having a priest
dictate to you what you should believe
or not so I'm not diminished priests at
all I'm just saying that ultimately it's
what people can experience and improve
and know for themselves which is one of
the reasons I people say oh what you're
saying sounds I believe I said well go
out and try this and and see if
something happens I I really am an
empiricist I think people need to rely
on their own ability to discover what
the truth is and not rely on myself or
any other expert to tell them what they
should or shouldn't believe I just think
people should engage in self discovery
and discovery in the world you you speak
in absolutes are you more absolute that
God exists or more absolute that
extraterrestrials exist
I don't think it's an either/or question
I'm okay I'm confident that both do
you're confident that both do okay
that's good to know is there any doubt
that you may be wrong
do you have any doubt you later oh well
there are a lot of things I don't know
but the things I do know I'll talk about
is because I know them you know I talk
about things that I have personal
knowledge of as opposed to things that
are second third fourth hand so if you
look at this subject on the internet
there's all kinds of wild theories based
on fourth hand conjectures I don't
engage in that the things that I that my
team and I have experienced directly we
know we've experienced and if you look
at this documentary there's this
wonderful story you may recall it from
the movie where this older gentleman who
had had a hearing loss since he was very
young I think since middle school high
school no when we were up in Arizona a
couple years ago doing the ce-5 contact
protocols and there was an ET that came
in faster than the speed of light zoom
there have been these objects up above
us and with we have photos and videos of
and this suddenly we heard something
behind us so a man who was on the team
with me named David Marconi who wrote
the screenplay for enemy of the state
that Will Smith was in so he had some
great camera so he swung it around the
lie said look there's something right
over here and he took a photo as we
heard this and there's this et this
extraterrestrial about five six feet
tall between a medical student who's on
our team and this man who had lost his
hearing and the man after this happened
continued having a contact with this et
throughout that evening and the next
morning he woke up and this a you know
40 a 50 year long hearing loss had been
completely reversed because he had asked
that to happen
now you know that story is you would say
well it's apocryphal but it's it's in
the documentary the photograph is in the
documentary of the experiences in there
now there's a lot behind what happened
in terms of what we did to set up the
conditions for that event but I've been
present at several thousand events like
that so so this is what makes me say you
know what I and other people with me
have seen and documented in photograph
that I am very confident about there's a
lot of other things that are out there
that are conjecture that I try to steer
away from yeah and by the way you know
you could tell the man who was able to
hear again when he got emotional you I
mean either he's an incredible actor and
he belongs in Hollywood or you just
could feel the level of sincerity yet
you know doc obviously you're not alone
when you look at the stats 33 percent of
US adults believe that some UFO
sightings over the years have in fact
been alien spacecraft visiting birds
from other planets or galaxies 33
percent is one-third that's that's a
pretty big number and then you have even
as most Americans are skeptical that
aliens have visited earth the majority
56 percent believe that those who spot
UFOs are seeing something real they're
not just imagining it so I'm a skeptic
I'm not coming from a place of I'm on
one side or another side but for me I
haven't had some of the experiences that
you've had and you're not somebody that
just all of a sudden you know you're a
conspiracy person that's just going out
there saying this you're somebody that's
a medical doctor you're somebody that's
you briefed and spoken at pentagon if
somebody that's gotten information out
there yeah this kind of leads me to the
next part when when you're thinking
about aliens to us we think about aliens
looking like the aliens in movies right
we think about them with the eyes and
how they look all that stuff from your
experience you said looking like a deer
six feet tall touched your right
shoulder what what if you've seen it
what do aliens look like
well before I answer that just remember
this every stable star system has
planets around it and the number of
intelligent civilizations that are
estimated to just be in our own galaxy
number in the millions let me repeat
that and we're one galaxy out of a
trillions of galaxies so what I'm going
to say then is that in our experience
and I'm just dealing with the 30 years
my team has gone out doing this we have
had sightings and encounters and with
almost the full gamut of types of life
forms for example in the movie there's
this one image of a being that's about
two feet tall on a beach in Florida and
it looks like almost like a hologram but
it's this crystalline figure that looks
like it has a halo it's actually a
toroidal energy a doughnut-shaped energy
field around it and that being was
standing in front of us as we were
setting up our team on the beach at near
boca grande and in Florida on the post
on the West Coast the Gulf Coast and the
but that beam was maybe at the most two
feet tall there are others that we have
documented that are over eight to ten
feet tall
there are different shape so the
caricature you see in Hollywood movies
and in most UFO stuff that's just so
most like a a racist caricature it's
sort of a joke and nobody in the
intelligence community takes those
seriously and this is part of the
problem because the mythology on this
subject is the dominant database that's
out there and the facts about the
subject or the hardest define so we're
trying to get some clarity on that
but yes you're quite correct or the ones
the image of the bug-eyed looking that
that sort of your your kind of
stereotypical being and there are a
couple of species that may look somewhat
like that but it is by no means what
most or all of them do
and my own understanding from the
experiences I've had with these ETS and
with people who are in the intelligence
community who work this subject and
classified programs is that none of them
are hostile but and they all have
different levels of the development but
in order for them to go on interstellar
and have that kind of technological
capability where you're moving from
point A to B across thousands or
millions of light-years of space that
technological capability means that your
society has evolved past where we are
where our sciences and technologies
could be our undoing if we use them for
war and I always mentioned to people
that this is one of the reasons why
civilizations that can evolve to that
level of Technology if they haven't
gotten their social and not religious
per se but spiritual inner development
high enough that the technologies are
going to be used to destroy their own
society like we almost have so these
civilizations are very advanced
intellectually socially spiritually and
technologically but the technology in
and of itself isn't the answer if you
have very advanced technology but you're
still running around like a bunch of
marauding chimpanzees you're gonna kill
yourself and everyone on the planet
because you're not talking about just
technologies as dangerous as a hydrogen
bomb you're talking about technologies
that are orders of magnitude more
powerful to transfer a spacecraft from
point A to B across space-time so when
you look at that you you kind of realize
that we're dealing with extraordinarily
advanced civilizations that have both
innate mental abilities intellectual
let's call it telepathic and other but
their technologies are also awesome
frankly when you observe these things
and how they move if you look at this
documentary
Encounters of the fifth kind you'll see
the object that will be here and almost
instant a teaming and instantly
computers here and and these are during
our ce-5 events and people go what I'm
going yes they're not moving in a
straight line and I remind people one of
our disclosure project witnesses was a
the man the chief investigator for the
federal government with FAA John
Callahan and there was a case in the 80s
where a Japan Airlines 747 heavy cargo
jet was going from Paris to Japan Tokyo
over the polar route and over Alaska
there was a UFO that appeared the size
of a battleship huge and it would appear
at yo nine o'clock it and then
instantaneously unless someone radar
sweep be hundreds of miles away the
opposite side and it moved nonlinearly
and over it's not in a line it would be
here and then here we have I have in my
archive the original FAA radar tape of
this that John Callahan handed off to me
the CIA thought they took it from his
office he gave them a copy I have the
original and we have the pilot statement
we have the account of the jet fighters
that were scrambled and we have the
radar tracing so I tell people the
content that we have is orders of
magnitude more significant than the
footage you're seeing on CNN and you
have to ask the question why isn't CNN
and Fox News doing that story that goes
back to project mocking but you're
talking about but yeah let me stay on
this I'm a math guy so for me
great and I'm by the way what's weird as
I grew up as a Christian family even
though was an atheist for 25 years and
I'm a big skeptic so I'm somebody that's
when you live in Iran and you see what
you see sometimes it's hard to believe
there's a god a loving God that wants
everything to be fine so I understand
that when I sit there and when I sit and
I look at the math and you look at
galaxies how many are there and you look
at me you do a simple search 200 billion
to 2 trillion or
that's the number that comes up 200
billion to 2 trillion or more so we know
of yeah now that we know what so it's
naive to say Oh 100% I know for there's
in no way in the world there's any
aliens well what is an alien what is an
extraterrestrial God that looks like in
movies we've only been around for a few
thousand years whether it's six thousand
years whatever number you want to say
with humans and mankind and all these
different numbers that you read about
it's kind of naive to be arrogant and to
think that somebody and some
civilization may not be out there or
whatever you want to talk about but the
other part is with the link between
water and Sun the distance for a galaxy
to be away from the Sun and knowing the
fact that you're in this world and I was
reading an article earlier saying the
fact that NASA found a somewhere a
planet that had water four-and-a-half
billion years ago etc it said I don't
know if you saw that article or not so
it could there be a possibility or maybe
you even know this based on research
that there is another planet with people
that look like us humans that oh there's
water there's you know people that are
building similar stuff to the US is
there any chance that that can also
exist yes I think it's very likely in
fact one of the species that we had a
contact with looked very similar to
humans and this is also in the
documentary it was an ET that appeared
in the desert at Joshua Tree National
Park with our team and I'm a person
right beside me that took a photograph
of this being and he actually looks very
similar to a human with a receding
hairline and the information we got from
him was that he was from the andromeda
galaxy which is about two and a half
million light-years from Earth which is
a twin galaxy to the Milky Way is a
spiral galaxy how many miles away 2.5
million light years so he has like the
ultimate uber to it on a figure out a
way to get over here yet here's the
thing to remember if
not dealing with linear distance does it
matter if you're dealing with a
non-local teleportation and
communication system so distance only
matters when you're locked into the
linear box of space-time when you're
technologies are advanced enough what
happens is that an entire spacecraft
they be enormous can actually resonantly
shift into what some people call another
dimension another field of energy
bypassed linear space-time and reappear
or rima t realized in another point and
that's actually how they're happening
now if you look at the science behind
there have been particle teleportation
experiences of that physicist and
experiments but we're talking doing this
on a macro level with an entire
spacecraft and everyone on board it but
again we're dealing with civilizations
that are 10 to the 6 the 10 to the 9th
years a hundred thousand to millions of
years more developed than we are and if
you were to go back I think it part of
this is human hubris that we think that
we're at the apex of technology if you
were to go back down the road from where
I'm sitting here is Thomas Jefferson's
home so if I were to go back in time and
show Thomas Jefferson my smartphone well
you might be burned at the stake as a
witch it would look like magic so almost
anything we have today if you showed
that to someone from 2,000 years ago the
time of the birth of Christ you'd be
lucky if you weren't burned as a witch
or a sorcerer it would look like magic
now let's extrapolate where we've come
just in the last hundred or 200 years of
the technological Industrial Revolution
let's extrapolate out a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand a million ten
million a billion years so in a universe
as at least 13 to 15 billion years old
it's a certainty that there are
civilizations that are that many orders
of magnitude more developed than we are
and so I think this is a get gets back
to this
importance of scientific empiricism
observation of facts because what we
have happened and it happens in society
all the time if someone observes
something that doesn't conform with the
paradigm they are pilloried and they are
thrown out of society I'll give an
example right here at the University of
Virginia some years ago a brilliant
doctor discovered that there was a type
of bacterium that was responsible for a
lot of the worst bleeding ulcers and
stomachs but because that ran against
the medical paradigm of it all being
cause of acid and dis and that he had to
leave America and ended up in Australia
now if you don't test if you have a
patient with a bleeding ulcer and you
don't test for this bacterium because if
it's there it's easily treated with
doxycycline if you don't test for that
it's medical malpractice but his life
was ruined and his reputation was ruined
because he dare speak the heresy of an
observed fact that ran against
scientific orthodoxy and what I'm saying
the public is the facts on this issue
aren't there they have to be recognized
as facts maybe if you could come to a
different conclusion than I have but as
Senator Daniel Patrick Moynihan said
everyone's entitled to their own opinion
but not their own set of facts so the
facts that we need to deal with
empirically as observed phenomenon have
to be accounted for now if our
scientific paradigm doesn't quite
account for all the strange things that
are observed it doesn't mean it's not
legitimate
it just means our science is very early
we're only in the first couple hundred
years of any real level of scientific
rigor and so there needs to be some
degree of humility on the part of humans
about the fact that we are sort of
one-half of one step out of the jungle
as a species but we're already dealing
with advanced
civilizations that are several orders of
magnitude past where we are and that's
okay I mean this is how civilizations
evolve I think I think you make a very
good point to say if we were to go back
2000 years ago in an iPhone what they
would react to it what happens if we go
a thousand years a hundred thousand
years I don't even know if we're gonna
make it that long out because of the
fact that we may have too much divisive
Ness and going at it should but
teleporting you said the fact that you
know how they teleport obviously see
that in movies and you wonder can we one
day have that technology
who knows maybe Warren Buffett sold his
shares in Airlines because he thinks
teleporting is the next phenomenon
experienced yet and actually exit
classified projects have already done
what you're suggesting classified
projects have already done teleporting
yes that's intense do you know if a
human has ever had sex with an alien I
do not know and nor do I want to know I
asked that quietly for no reason I asked
that question for a different reason I
seriously doubt it okay yeah I asked
that because I wonder when you saying
you know the person that had a hairline
you know receding hairline and he looked
like even the topic got me coughing
human you miss having sex for most will
enemy of the movie Avatar you know an
avatar how the guy falls in love with
the alien I don't know if you've seen a
movie avatar but I wonder if there was
any stories there so what do you what
are your thoughts about area 51 well
that you know that's a grid name so the
actual proper name is the Nevada Test
range and Nellis Air Force Base and to
be specific in what the culture calls
area 51 nobody in my circle calls it
that the key names are s 3 S 4 s 9 s 12
Groom Lake pollute Mesa so there are two
parts of that operation
the ones that there's part of it that is
the energy transfer part where they are
studying retrieved extraterrestrial
vehicles that we have when we have these
and and studying how they operate all
the different systems and then there's a
another part of it where they are
building up human let's call it reverse
engineered as close as we can get
versions of those so there are two sets
of operations there are almost no
contact between the people in the dumb
the deep underground military base where
the et crafts are held that are working
on the other if there's sort of a
firewall but things are transferred but
the people working on the one are not
just going back and forth I know men who
worked on both I also know the Air Force
Office of Special Investigations officer
who investigated one of these objects we
were test flying that was actually an ET
object but we couldn't figure out the
energy system properly so we put on a
portable nuclear power plant on it that
unfortunately had a malfunction and it
went down over the outskirts of Houston
and irradiated a lot of civilians there
and this is called the cash Landrum case
if you want to google it and this man
came forward a couple years ago and
confirm that those were actually for
human pilots trying to get this ET
object to operate but they had this
power source on it that had a
malfunction that unfortunately radiated
the people below and of course the
military denied knowledge of it and in
fact the people who were approached by
both the media and the public that the
injured parties actually sued the US
government and it got tossed out because
the government said we have no knowledge
of that but the truth is the ones who
were being asked did have no knowledge
that's the nature of a highly
compartmented unacknowledged special
access project but
that craft that malfunctioned over
outside Houston I would believe it was
in the early 80s that was from the
Nellis range from the the part that had
this this study group that was working
on the et object now there are other
facilities that are actually much more
important than that one outside of Salt
Lake City
outside Provo there's something called
the Dugway proving grounds and there's a
very large underground facility there
that in my team members have been -
there's an underground facility at
Edwards Air Force Base and up in the
high desert of California and near
Palmdale and Lancaster and the the
Lockheed skunkworks and the really key
facilities there are also underground
and you know so we know where a number
of these facilities are you know over
the years I've developed relationships
as I mentioned with hundreds of people
who worked and are currently working in
those facilities who give us information
you're starting to concern me because I
have an office in Palmdale and the
people there concern me every once in a
while when I work with them but they're
probably gonna see this but uh you know
talking about area 51's 3s 12 you know
the place you talk about improbable
outside of Pro Bowl what is in there
like are they holding ufos or
extraterrestrial aliens maybe are they
holding him hostage what what is in
there somebody was able to sneak in
there what are we gonna see well we have
980 whistleblower so I'm curious
somebody's probably giving any
information on that oh yeah a lot the
the facilities have et craft that are
stored the bodies it most of the folks
did not survive the downing of the
object and retrieval of those are stored
there autopsy and then stored I know a
man at Fort Huachuca in Arizona which is
Army intelligence headquarters and out
from that base underground is a facility
where there are nine different
ET craft that over the years have been
retrieved and a number of bodies that
are stored there
are they living living galo they're all
dead no they're all that did not so we
don't have any living aliens at any of
our locations that you know of if there
are any currently I don't know about it
I do know that one that lived and
survived after the so called Roswell
event which actually did happen but it's
not what you think it's not what you've
been told but one of them did live at
least until 1951 and I have an army
intelligence officer who actually saw
that being in a cage in near Camp Perry
near Williamsburg Virginia not too far
from where I am I understand that that
particular being died not long after
that that's in public do you know what
they eat like I really don't I mean I
wouldn't want the extra I personally
don't have information about that I'm
sure there are different civilizations
and they eat different things
is he gonna I mean I wonder what they're
gonna say I wonder like a medium-rare
hamburger you know what she's like
American that I don't know yes I'd be
curious because maybe I bet they're
probably fun conversations to have with
them a few few last items here before we
wrap up what are your what are your
biggest concerns with future threats you
know we have a lot of people right now
that are worried about many different
things they're worried about you know
what's gonna happen with us in China
what's gonna happen with oil what's
gonna happen with coronavirus pandemics
bio warfare cyber war what are you what
do you think is the biggest threat in
the future
I think it may be unfolding right now
and as a medical doctor I'm appalled and
shocked at how we have managed and
mismanaged this Cove in nineteen crisis
we don't have time to go into all that
but the folks I have who worked at Fort
Detrick
in the bio warfare army have confirmed
to me that that was in fact a bio
engineered virus that the response that
we're having to it is likely to kill
many more people than the virus could in
other words because of the collapse of
the economy somewhere around two to
three million people may die from
poverty unemployment not getting medical
attention early enough for heart attacks
and strokes many of my emergency doctor
friends are telling me this they were
still in the ER I'm not in the ER right
now and if you add all those deaths up
there are about three to four times the
number of possible deaths from kovat 19
and so you know what a lot of countries
did they get locked down and then they
had widespread testing and then they
opened up society so things could begin
to get back to normal
well we didn't do that because there's
no widespread testing of either
antibodies or the virus enough to know
what we're doing at but at the same time
because of that people are wanting to
extend into 2021 some people are saying
2022 aspects of this lockdown well that
will leave our economy in ashes and if
you're a public health official you
can't just look at one metric I eat
coconuts you've also got to look at all
the people who are gonna die from
alcoholism suicide murder a wife
beatings heart attacks strokes poverty
not getting medical care on and on and
on and on and on and when you add all
those up you end up getting a number
from what we're doing to respond to the
virus that far exceeds the worst
possible estimates of deaths from the
virus if we even will let it run them up
so it's probably the most poorly managed
crisis that I have observed in my
lifetime and I was born in 1955 and how
would you have done it how would you
have done it would you have taken a
sweet on approach yes a modified Sweden
approach where there would have been
through the Defense Authorization Act
massive standing up of testing for both
the virus and antibodies so we would
know exactly where it is contain it but
then let the the rest of society
function as normally as possible for
example in Sweden it's against the wall
not to send your children to school and
what I'm seeing in ARCA I have nine
grandchildren I have a tenth on the way
and what I'm seeing is that we're and
even though they're you know in the flu
season a couple years ago 172 children
died his flute there were only been
three CDC reported deaths of children
from coronavirus so we have to figure a
way to do this in a smart way
but to do it in a smart way we would
have to stand up competence from federal
and state governments to do ubiquitous
testing and we haven't done that we
squandered four months since January and
by the way the people I know in the
military of the people with PhDs in
biological warfare this was on their
radar in December of 2019 and it was
known now it's been proven now that the
virus was loose in our society in
December of 2019 in Europe and the
United States so we've lost four months
where we should have stood up that
capability and infrastructure but if we
if we stay on the path we're on with
this is open-ended lockdown the number
of deaths from poverty and unemployment
and I think frankly will enter into
something worse than the Great
Depression if we're not careful that the
son my mother grew up during the Great
Depression and the consequences of that
and the death from that would be greater
than from the virus itself so now the
other concern I have
as someone who's you might put my
mother's family were the unfortunate
early losers in the Revolutionary War
with the British and we're the first
prisoner war with the British in the
Pennsylvania Dutch and what what what
I'm looking at is what happens well like
I was at my home in DC recently at the
Safeway in a nice neighborhood there
were a cluster of Army National Guard
people and a phalanx of police at the to
go buy your bread so the concern I have
is this virus being used to engage in
excessive police state tactics that
suspend freedom of assembly freedom of
speech freedom all kinds of freedoms and
freedom to make a living and freedom to
have the pursuit of happiness now is
there a balance it needs to be struck
absolutely
we need widespread ubiquitous testing
contact tracing while we open society up
and that is what should have happened
beginning in January the ball got
dropped in January February March April
we've still dropped that ball I'm just
being blunt with you as a as any
emergency doctor and there other
emergency doctors who have said the same
thing but their videos have been banned
off of YouTube yeah plenty of them do
you believe there's an element of
Project Mockingbird taking place or no a
hundred percent or do you think any any
commentators any of these major anchor
x' that you see on CNN MSNBC Fox ABC any
of these guys do you think any of them
could potentially be also CIA agents or
no they don't know about its
behind-the-scenes executives well the
way that works is that you're talking
about the teleprompter junkies monkeys I
mean they're the ones reading they're
the ones that the ones the editors the
national security and key editors at
this
this story runs this story doesn't
that's the control point not the people
who are the talent let's call it that's
on the camera so it's that it's the
control system behind the camera and the
editors and who decides what story is
run and what isn't
writes that how much what said is is
what the anchor takes ownership what and
how much of it is the editor that wrote
it and he's simply reading you know
she's reading it but both was happening
obviously but who the what's decided to
be on that program goes through a filter
and that's where you get into the
problem now I think so there have been
on all the networks and physicians and
others that have surfaced and said
here's what we need to be doing and
there are others who have said look
what's gone on in Sweden they may have
heard immunity and by June or July what
I think in the United States we have the
worst of both worlds because we we on
the one hand we have a lockdown
situation and a suspension of normal
activities that have suspended basic
individual and civil rights and business
and has had massive economic damage but
at the same time we haven't done what
let's say China and other like a turret
Aryan regime like China was able to walk
and and test and trace everything but
even democracies like Germany or
Portugal for that matter or South Korea
they were able to do very widespread
testing and you know here we have the
United States a medical superpower a
technological superpower a financial
superpower fumbling around incompetently
but for example a lot of people don't
know that in nursing homes if someone
starts having symptoms of CO vat19 that
test that they will get for that person
is considered a priority to which means
it takes 8 to 10 days to get the results
back but that's where most of the deaths
are happening is it sweeping through
elderly and sick populations so almost
all of the policies that have been
enforced to manage this pandemic
then upside down I'm just unfortunately
I'm sorry to bit on your show like this
but I'm just outraged by it frankly as a
dog I mean I appreciate you sharing that
I mean I'm curious to know from somebody
in your world by the way quick a run
down here with alien movies how much of
it is fiction how much of it is real and
how much of it has some truth behind it
men in black 99% fiction 99% fiction
aliens the movie a hundred percent
fiction I never did
Independence Day that's scripted right
out of central casting at CIA because
they want everyone to unite around an
alien threat and that's our folks signs
I never saw it oh really I think you
ought to see it it's it has a lot to do
with one of the fiber encounters it's
interesting a calmer field hmm I don't
know I'm sure I can tell you that Close
Encounters of the Third Kind was a
docudrama I have a doctor as well yeah
what do you think about the movie Star
Trek are you a fan of it oh they're fun
I mean you know I mean of course it's
sort of a anthropomorphic procedure
we're basically projecting the human
condition out in space with you know
cowboys and Indians shooting at each
other and all that I think it's it's you
know it's great fantasy I don't think
there's any legitimacy to what the way
things actually are are you more
attractive are you more Star Wars guy
yourself well if they're all science
fiction and they all have their pluses
and minuses I kind of like the whole
Yoda if you look at the Jedi mind trick
I mean that there's a lot of cool stuff
that George Lucas worked into that just
like Close Encounters of the Third Kind
well you did say some of the aliens you
met are two feet tall so I mean you know
that he kind of fits the description
yes yeah by the way you've done DC is
seeing five events that you do and then
folks come from all over the world who
are some of the most mentionable names
that have come through politicians
wealthy folk celebrities you know that
you can mention their names anybody that
comes to those events with you well I
wouldn't want to name folks like that I
mentioned David Marconi who
a renowned writer you know the actor
that played in babe
Jamie Cromwell he's been out with us and
we had a massive object come over us
near Palm Springs in California he
actually sort of played me in the Star
Trek movie first contact his old funny
story he was gonna do the opening for
that Star Trek movie first contact where
in the human first made contact and he
was sort of used what I had been doing
as an inspiration for his role and with
the at the premiere in London Prince
Charles was going to come and had
communicated that he wanted to get the
briefing document I put together for the
president so I gave it to Jamie Cromwell
who and the reception line gave it to
Prince Charles and I got a lovely note
back from Prince Charles about it that's
my husband Prince Charles and Prince
Philip are very interested in all this
yeah there's some there's some big names
I mean I have a list here of Churchill
oh yes obviously Jimmy Carter you know
you got some of the people in Hollywood
Katy Perry Megan Fox Shatner yes
knocking Ridley Scott there's a lot Bill
Nighy a lot of folks that are believers
of it so it's not like it's a small
community here by the way for somebody
that's a doctor are you what are your
thoughts on vaccines any any opinions on
vaccines yourself or no well I think
that most people have
there have been vaccines that had
problems I think a lot of those have
been resolved I think it's very
dangerous for our children not to get
vaccinated for the worst sort of
communicable diseases that are out there
I came up in an era when we didn't have
a measles vaccine we didn't have a lot
of the ones we take for granted now
there were a lot of children who were
killed and harmed I had the worst case
of measles and chickenpox our
pediatrician had ever seen yourself
myself yeah almost died so I you know
these are these are fearsome diseases so
what happens with this is that there are
some bad outcomes and but then
the whole baby gets thrown out with the
bath water and I think we need to be
careful but we do need transparency
about which vaccines have had what side
effects and a lot of times big profit
centered pharmaceutical companies will
minimize that and we know the FDA is
utterly incompetent to look out after
these things frankly so and so it's the
CDC I mean look how they'd manage this
crisis I mean I've never seen such
incompetence but ouch but I mean you
asked my opinion I'm not gonna up coach
Shanker I thought it was great and
Bothell if they come up with a corona
virus vaccine would you take you to
yourself actually I think in January I
actually had a co good 19 I'm waiting to
see if I get an antibody test but I had
every symptom you would expect and so I
predict that I have a pretty high titer
and you need a way nobody whiter your
June 28 1955 right right yeah I'll be 65
in June yeah so so you're so you're in
that age range that they're sometimes
concern about they say 70 plus but I was
just wondering you don't seem like you
were to concern about it uh well I mean
I mountain-bike 60 miles a week and
hiked 20 miles a week and benchpress 400
pounds and I'm in the gym when it's open
all the time and are you guys are in
there my guys in under 20 s have a hard
time keeping up with me so I'm not your
classic 60 something I'm more like a 40
year old that's 60 something I'm
impressed by the way you're also good
smack talker you know the way you said
it you were like listen you know 400
hundred you see how he said it
400 pounds and I've been not a lot of
people want to go against a mention 400
pounds your speed around I'll give you a
name or top it just give me one word
that comes to mind Bob Lazar true okay
storm area 51 fantasy x-files fantasy
David flavor honest I don't know okay
Steven Spielberg brilliant interstellar
excellent
Frank pepper don't know Sara Seager no
no no dr. harrell part hath a probe cut
off intelligence operative Travis Walton
misrepresented by Hollywood he had a
real experience but it was
misrepresented by Hollywood Helen Sharma
don't know no known Trump aspirational
aspirational Hillary Clinton past past
ok foul Qi misguided CDC incompetent
you've been amazing this has been an
incredible conversation I'm gonna put
the links to your website for the
articles you shared with we will also
put the links of your two books below as
well
for those are you see it and we will
also put the link below to the
documentary that you had which was
incredible when I watch it I highly
recommend everybody watch and it it it
goes by like this because it by the time
it's done with you feel like it was five
minutes and I thought it was very well
put together and again dr. Greer I
appreciate you for coming out and
spending a couple hours with us ardor
for having spent the last two hours with
you once again thank you for being a
guest somebody taemin I appreciate it
thank you the topic of aliens they make
for good movies but are they the truth
are they a myth has he changed your mind
after the conversation with dr. Greer I
want to hear your thoughts comment below
and if you've not seen any of the other
interviews on our channel this your
first time comments about you tainment
here's a playlist of some of the best
interviews we've done if you've not seen
won't click on them to go through them
and if you're not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]